so Tony I'm starting a new series asking
people what their favorite books are
what the recommendations are for
entrepreneurs and as a best-selling
author when you see that people are
struggling with things are outside their
control I wonder what your advice would
be and what kind of books you'd
recommend people to read what can you do
you know when things are seem to be
outside your control
alright the biggest thing I've always
tried to show people is you become
indispensable by constantly finding way
to add more value wherever you are in
your life to your family to your friends
but certainly in business that's the
competitive Vantage and so if you work
for somebody else you have a job or your
own company being indispensable
everything and I read a book recently by
Seth Gooden that really is it's called
linchpin and I'm a big fan of Seth's
he's a friend of mine he's just he's a
he's very poetic and he's brilliant and
he takes complex things and makes them
very simple but writes them in a very
inspiring way so I chose book right now
but these days I've eaten my iPads so
I'd really go pick up his book I think
it's really tiny could read it really
quick and I think it'd give you some
really nice insights and then one of the
book I'd just like to recommend to you
I mean features have a little bit of
time here it's called the happiness
hypothesis by Jonathan hate and probably
missed bouncing his name I hope I'm not
but it's a book I read when it first
came out several years ago but it's one
of the best books I've read to show you
the scientific understanding of how you
really experience a life of fulfillment
because as things get more difficult the
old style of being happy that so many
people used up you know let me just get
what I want we all know that doesn't
work but it becomes more obvious when
the economy contracts and I just one of
my missions is to make sure people are
really truly fulfilled in their lives on
that day I believe that happens by
contribution by relationships by making
a difference by having your life have
meaning beyond yourself and yes you can
get your toys and I've had the privilege
of doing that but it never fills anybody
up this book let me tell you that in a
few words or some silly little quote I
think it'll give you some stuff that's
real food for thought it will move you
and it'll kind of give you a little
pathway to see what are the real ways to
have lasting happiness and fulfillment
so just what I recommend those two books
do you hope you find them really useful
thank you guys so much for watching I
love to know if you've read either those
two books and what you think of them as
well as the idea for this new
you is that I'm thinking about
showcasing famous entrepreneurs and
their favorite books that hopefully rub
a little bit of book knowledge and magic
off on you guys
let me know if you think this series
should continue and be extended leave it
in the comments below I'll join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching and to believe in a season